à partir du moment où on avait donc un
petit à petit en studio pour le premier
10 c'est moi qui ai fait qu'il ait fait
donc gg enregistrer les morceaux dans
mon studio dans nos studios
après je les ai
je les ai fait graver à londres faisant
des bonds studio de gravure gc fait
presser en france j'ai imprimé des
pochettes et je les vends un des
distributeurs en france qui après les
dispatche à des distributeurs à
l'étranger
kir et dispatcher les distributeurs et
on peut retrouver des disques dans le
monde entier il arrive à une époque
musicale est ouvert pour tous seuls on
s'attend à ce qu'elle a trop l'habitude
d'avoir des barrages des produits des
produits finis de merde qui me casse les
couilles mais aussi des faits
du danemark de suède
[Applaudissements]
du japon de new york alors que
en u15 minimisant mais savons-nous
vraiment que ça peut payer à la fois un
public à la fois des gens
sont intéressés par cette
amar tou
et comble vraiment atteindre en faisant
des trucs en sachant mois
sommes des gens à l'autre bout de la
terre daft punk les punks de timbres et
les nouvelles coqueluches techno de
l'angleterre viennent de france et casse
la baraque
signé sur un petit label indépendant
écossais leur premier single ont été
acclamés par la critique internationale
qualifiée de new wave new wave par une
presse anglaise surexcités guy manuel de
homem christo et thomas bangalter à
peine 40 ans à eux deux font de la
musique ensemble depuis leurs 15 ans il
compose et produisent leur musique dans
un studio installé dans leur chambre
dans la grande tradition des petits
génies de la techno house ameutés par la
persistante rumeur anglaise les grandes
maisons de disques françaises les
courtise depuis plusieurs mois avec le
chéquier à la main les daft punk ne cède
pas pour l'instant bien décidé à dicter
leurs règles et à garder le contrôle
thomas bangalter vient de lancer rouler
son propre mini label petits tirages
mais distribution mondial attention les
jeunes loups français de la techno son
redoutable
oui
mon
enfin
[Musique]
et
et tout a été qu'ils aient beaucoup
autour de sa basse et la tente de
prendre des vacances et voir si on
arrive à faire la musique vraiment et
pas seulement un manceau puisqu'ils
emilia presse a tendance à faire gonfler
les trucs budget
j'espère que nous on va pas se planter
pour une fois ça va continuer à bien
marcher pas besoin que c'est peut-être
un peu gros score